[Music]
it's been a year since Russia first
occupied Crimea and nearly a year since
a full-blown separatist conflict broke
out in eastern Ukraine we in the West
tend to look at this conflict solely
through the lens of Russian aggression
but there's so much more to understand
you need to understand Ukraine's history
and in particular how that history has
left the country with deep political
linguistic economic just fundamental
national divisions so we can see this
first of all by just looking at a pretty
basic political map of Ukraine if you
look at the results in the election that
brought Yanukovych to power you can see
that the eastern regions of the country
were far more likely to support
Yanukovych and the western regions were
far more likely to support Timoshenko
and the interesting thing about that is
the that political divide that you see
comes up in a ton of different aspects
of Ukraine's history and geography so
one area is the linguistic divide the
divides of the different regions of the
country that are predominantly
russian-speaking as opposed to
predominantly Ukrainian speaking really
closely mirrored that political divide
Russia went through a series of policies
to do what they called rusev occation in
the 1700s under Catherine the Great so
this goes back hundreds and hundreds of
years those policies involved everything
from settling ethnic Russians in those
regions to forbidding people from
speaking the Ukrainian language that
continued well into the 20th century
Stalin essentially orchestrated this
massive famine
that killed millions of people in
Ukraine after that they increased the
resettlement of Russians into Ukraine
you were left with a Ukraine that looked
very different parts of the country were
much more likely to speak Russian be
culturally Russian and be ethnically
Russian and it's had a lasting impact on
the country as a whole
fast forward to modern Ukraine when
Yanukovych was elected he was
negotiating with the EU about a deal
that would have brought closer
EU ties so then when he abandoned that
and took a bailout from Russia instead
that was perceived as him really kind of
turning away from the west and turning
towards Russia and that was very
controversial it prompted protests that
were largely clustered in the western
part of the country and the capital city
Kiev and eventually it forced young
Kovich out of office point is that this
is not just Russia invading Ukraine the
point is that there are Ukrainian
separatists who are actively trying to
achieve independence from Kyiv different
parts of Ukraine have a very different
idea of what kind of country Ukraine
should be and that doesn't make it ok
that doesn't make it acceptable as a
matter of international law it just
certainly doesn't justify what Russia
has been doing but it also shouldn't be
something that you ignore
[Music]